nuevas restricciones navideñas en
alemania desde este lunes una forma de
reducir el riesgo de expansión del cobi
19 que muchos alemanes están aceptando
y creo que las preocupaciones tienen
sentido y me adapto a ellas creo que
funcionan bien no noto ninguna
restricción importante en mi vida
privada
pero también genera dudas en otros
las reglas son muy diferentes sería
mejor si fueran uniformes a todos los
estados alemanes
como bien dice este alemán en mclain
burgo antepomerania desde este lunes han
cerrado cines teatros museos y la parte
cubierta de los jardines zoológicos en
brandeburgo y baja sajonia hasta el 11
de enero habrá un límite en las
reuniones de 10 personas sin contar
niños en baden-württemberg varios
restaurantes y otros establecimientos
deberán cerrar entre las diez y media de
la noche y cinco de la madrugada excepto
el 31 de diciembre que cerraran a la una
de la madrugada
la incidencia se sitúa este lunes en 222
contagios por 100.000 habitantes un
descenso respecto a la pasada semana sin
embargo los epidemiólogos avisan de que
puede estar provocado por las fiestas de
navidad ya que la variante o micro
aumentando su difusión ante esto la
prioridad es vacunar así habló el
presidente frank walter steinmeier el
día de navidad
hemos aprendido que no somos impotentes
podemos protegernos a nosotros mismos y
a los demás me alegra que la mayoría de
la gente haya reconocido la oportunidad
que brinda la vacunación tiende en
franklin alemania actualmente tiene un
70 por ciento de la población inoculada
el gobierno espera va a tener al 80 por
ciento de los alemanes con al menos una
dosis para el 7 de enero pero la fecha
se ha hasta finales de mes